all right
anthony where are you from originally
born in
torrance i
moved to palmdale lancaster when i was
in the fifth grade
i went to college in santa barbara
sbcc
it's a community college
and uh
here i am
at skate row
skid row that's what college education
gets you
yeah yeah
tell me about your family
my family
they divorced
my dad's an immigrant
they divorced when i was
eight years old
roughly i guess
uh
now yeah now looking back on it it's
it's
you know he was
doing too much to try to keep her she
had obviously already left
you know
women don't
just decide one day oh i think i'm gonna
leave him you know they monkey branch
like
when you're left you're already left you
know what i mean they are they have a
place they're moving into tonight with
some other guy you know what i mean not
like oh i'm just
decided hey i'm gonna try my luck
how would you describe your childhood
mr
well
i mean i i had
i had things you know what i
i guess um
i
weren't completely broke but
uh i never
like i didn't i didn't have family or
nothing no extended family just what i
had my mom and
you know
they worked a lot
and then
i did my own thing
[Music]
started drinking
like 13 we would go pimp
pimp beer
[Music]
that's what we would call it you know we
go ask people to buy us beer at the
store you know
keystone or natural ice or natural light
and uh
yeah then we drink it in my garage at
night
i smoked weed first in the fifth grade
uh
i tried acid
in the sixth or seventh grade
uh
i worked
like a full
you know what i mean i always i always
had a job even though i was like you
know
i drank a lot
and i didn't actually start doing real
drugs until i was 30 years old
how old do you know 40.
so you started late compared to most of
the people down here yeah yeah that's
what i
who does that you know i didn't start on
pills or nothing i went right to black
tar heroin
i was sick one day
like i had the flu
i was going to work
uh
and i wasn't going to make it i tried to
call in
they said oh brandon had already called
in so i had to go in
and my friend i knew he dabbled and [ __ ]
and he said hey you want to put some pep
in your step
and
yeah
so now your drug is i went from the flu
to being more productive than i did
normally you know what i mean
like i put the whole stock order away
all that [ __ ]
and uh i felt great he gave me another
little foil that i could smoke you know
like midday or would it you know and
then
and then i started what they call
chipping
you know where i'd
every week or two weeks or every month
you know i'd buy a bag or buy two bags
and then i hit the point of no return
and then i was addicted to heroin you
know which was weird
it wasn't like i thought it would be i
was still super productive i was
you know working full-time
i had two other side hustles and then i
was still
uh doing cars on the on the side i would
buy head gaskets off of craigslist you
know blown head gaskets
as opposed to the auction where you know
they're bidding for stuff that's
you know
when people take in a car for for a head
gasket repair
they already assumed the money you know
it
is out of the car so they ask a much
lower price
and
it's fairly cheap for me to repair so
that's what i would look for on there
and i was you know
firing those out
and
it was it was
you know
your drug today is
fentanyl and chris fentanyl and crystal
meth
what's that you're smoking right now
this is a mix of fentanyl and crystal
meth
i don't have much left that's why i'm
actually here
you've been married before
no i
i got engaged once but
didn't work out
no kids
no kids
luckily thank god
[Music]
thank god no kids
and you're staying aware now
i'm homeless
you're in a tent or just on the street
i'm homeless i uh
went
in a tent
right now although i don't have a tent
at all like i'm just
yeah you're just a body on the street
kind of yeah just roving just going
wherever
uh i was in the tiny homes a minute ago
uh i left or got thrown out about
six seven days ago i'm back on the
street
[Music]
they
yeah how do you support yourself
uh
like side jobs
side jobs
asking people for money
i burned up everything that i had
you know if if anything
savings you know it's all
day-to-day
i got
yeah
how's it you've been living like this
how long
as of now you know
it's crazy to say like five years five
years been about five years
how does it affect you emotionally
living like this
um
without the dope there's no way i could
do it there's no way i could be homeless
without you know
it keeps me numb enough to you know
uh
i've
i've changed a lot you know what i mean
uh
when i came out here i was really green
and like you know friendly
you know and now i realize that
everything's
a fake scam to rip you off you know
every other homeless person is scum
all they want to do is steal your stuff
and some
[Music]
some of them actually have
those intentions
before they meet you you know like i
would come over here and befriend you
because oh you need some help with your
camera stuff but i really want to steal
your cameras that's why i'm here you
know
it's not just like an opportunistic
thing
and
you know and then
when you're missing it help you look for
it
you know it could be something you use
for work
you know every day and you need it and
you have kids and you have this you know
and they'll sell it for you know forty
dollars when it's worth two grand you
know just
everyone's a hustler and a con artist
down here
yeah for the most part
everyone they all
claim to not steal oh i don't steal not
me i'm not the one
they all do i initially worked for all
my [ __ ] you know
so it
it it hurt me when people stole my [ __ ]
you know what i mean like it's not like
oh i
come up every day
it's you know what i mean i come up i
just
so it's like a revolving door people
take the [ __ ] so what it doesn't matter
because i have new [ __ ] right here you
know that i just took
wasn't like that for me so i would get
really [ __ ] you know uh
i i've had basically everything
everything i have is is stolen so i said
you know you want to steal [ __ ] from me
now [ __ ] go ahead i got
you know what i mean i can't watch my
[ __ ] 24 hours a day
and remain sane there's no way i can do
that i wouldn't care too if i could
i wouldn't care too if i could
uh
do you mind if i
just open the door just for a second
do you have any friends
i don't talk to no one that i used to
uh a few of them would probably hit me
if they saw me like this
and
really
do people really even have friends you
know
every relationship seems to run its
course
whether it be
you know
friends family
relationships
yeah a lot of people have a hard time
connecting
well maintaining connections
you know what
what is a friend you know someone
i i guess i would consider that you
could call in the middle of the night
and would come pick you up you know if
you right
help you out in a jam
and
would expect me to do the same for them
oh
so if i don't work and i don't
have a car like what is the only jam i
could be and not having any drugs
no
yeah
yeah it's it's all it's all [ __ ]
uh
i'm
the first time in like
since i've been here since
seven years
i haven't had a
significant other
that's great
how did you first get introduced to
heroin
i had my my friend
corey
[Music]
we we lived together
i met him through
uh
another acquaintance
we rented a house in simi valley
i uh
the house i was in before i got a big
cash for keys deal
uh bank gave me 10 grand right
not to ruin this house that i didn't
plan on ruining anyway you know
and uh that was enough to get us into
another big like five five bedroom house
and uh
the rent was 2 800 a month
and there was four of us
and uh anyway
one of one of the guy one of the guys
there
corey
uh
he he did dope you know he'd been
dabbling with ob opiates his whole life
uh he he's i know he started on pills
and all this [ __ ] and you know i i i
would just drink all the other three of
us drank you know
uh like joe was the big drunk type the
guy i met him through was like you know
the
the big dumb idiot who always you could
say let's go have some beer and he'll
always go with you
like that kind of guy and then
my friend that i grew up with kyle
[Music]
he drank like a bottle of svedka every
night that vodka
[Music]
so
like
i knew it was the same thing as
as vicodin and you know all that stuff i
know i know it all comes from the same
place you know i'm not
completely out of the loop
but i never
like if i broke my arm or something or
hurt myself you know or if they gave me
a prescription a hydrocodine
i would i would do them and then it
would be over like i would
i wouldn't actively seek it out you know
i would like
i just wouldn't do that or
if i was at a party or something and
someone had said hey you want to bike it
in like yeah i'll i'll take it you know
and i would like take two of them and
get hot flashes and start to get sick
want to throw up you
know but then that would be the end of
it like i wouldn't actively seek it out
ever
uh
when i was sick for work like i said
that one day you know
like i had the flu man i was bad like i
woke up and i puked in the sink i was
like
like the sickest i've ever been in my
life one of the one of the worst you
know i was like there's no way i can go
to work right now
like i wouldn't want me at work right
now you know
so i
i called in but
i i i couldn't really sit it out because
there's only three people one had
already called in
there would have been
two people would have called out there
would have only been one person there
wasn't
it wouldn't have worked
and then so i went from
feeling like [ __ ] you know to
being
just as productive if not more you know
what i mean by smoking some
black
plant matter on a foil
i was like this is
pretty cool you know
not to mention i thought you know what i
mean i felt [ __ ] great
and uh
as soon as i started that too i put the
bottle down like
i quit drinking like immediately like it
it
it doesn't like
bring any more pleasure drinking it just
like makes me impaired it doesn't even
you know what i mean you don't get no
euphoric feeling from it or i don't
anyway you know
i guess it's not enough to overcome the
dope you know it's just
drinking is just
it'll either make me fall asleep or
you know
probably be an [ __ ]
the
so yeah i i didn't
i didn't drink anymore and and i was bad
you know i was drinking i was drinking a
lot you know i mean every day since i
was 13 you know really
or every third day or you know
binging on weekends
you know
sit there on a tuesday wednesday or
thursday night you know
by myself and just get [ __ ] up you
know drinking an
18 pack on the couch alone you know
waking up the next morning all dry for
work you know
what are you worried about what are you
afraid of now
i'm afraid of now
um
really
i've done a lot of things and i've been
a lot of places i've lived a full life
you know i'm not afraid of
not afraid of dying or anything
i hate that my my youngest sister you
know that i wasn't able to be there for
her
see my
my parents they moved to idaho
recently too while i wasn't looking ah
here's the problem with a step dad you
know
her step parents you know
it's got to be hard for them i think
it's harder with a male too
you know to
to raise someone else's kid you know
what i mean
as your own because it's not true you
know
i mean
realistically you know
and you could try or or whatnot but you
know
every
relationship is going to have its
problems
and
if that kid
if you give him the means to be more
successful than you right
now where does that leave you you know
what i mean no one needs your ass
see like think about it look look at
people who are
you know what i mean step dad's a
situation they won't allow that kid to
thrive i believe you know what i mean
because then it opens the door for them
to you know
be thrown out flat on their face for the
[ __ ] they've worked for for 10 or 20
years
you think you'll stay in this situation
rest your life
you see getting out
yeah i i i don't even know
i don't even know like
i i think i'm generally happy you know
i treat people well better than i did
you know when i was
it makes me realize what matters
more uh
you know
as
as long as the people are pleasant to me
when they walk up to me i'm perfectly
you know
i i don't yeah i don't know if i'll stay
like this forever
uh what am i supposed to do like go to
work again and
[Music]
get a job and
buying a house and like like
for what it's pointless
are there some positives about this
lifestyle staying
what are there are there some positives
about this lifestyle of living on the
street and not having responsibility
yeah there's a lot less stress yeah i
mean
stress is a killer you know and i mean
everyone knows that
you know
you're stressed out but in different
yeah different kind of stress
it's a different kind
exactly you know
i think you know that long-term dwelling
you know like oh [ __ ] uh
you know i can't get fired i have to do
this i have to you know
produce and then you know you got kids
to worry about and this and that
like that constant worrying [ __ ] i think
that
knocks years off your life you know
uh
the uh
was like that uh
do you have a regret
huh do you have regrets
regrets
um
i wish
that i hide the knowledge that i do now
younger
you know
that would have been that would have
been great because
i used to be
a major [ __ ] all the time you know
i think it closed a lot of doors for me
you know or just knowing how
i feel like i'm
more adapted to
people now i can you know
talk with basically anyone and i think
that would have helped me a lot if i
would have known that younger but would
that have changed my situation the one
i'm in now no probably not you know
oh i'm home i'm homeless
i don't want to work
i worked my whole life and i i i don't
have [ __ ] to show for it you know what i
mean
i i worked for my for my parents you
know what i mean
and uh
i tried as hard as i could you know what
i mean and
in this one business you know and i did
i re really i did
i made it successful i i did that you
know
that was the hardest i could have tried
i believe that
and they
fired me and kicked me out of the house
for it
so
like
it
for for what and then these people like
driving around and
honking their horns at people because
they're not like
making a right turn fast enough you know
what i mean it's it it's just it's crazy
to me how
dumb p they are and then they
they watch a two-minute news slot you
know that fits into the commercials
and you know oh that's it you know what
i mean
and then they tell you what you should
think too
by saying well what do you think about
the fire well i think that these guys
down the street started it you know what
i mean
it's they're they're working people to
death for
their own benefit
and i don't i wake up whenever i want
you know
there's
cool times in homelessness it's like an
abundance of [ __ ] you know like you
either have
no change in your pocket
for no soda or you have two shopping
carts full of them you know what i mean
uh all kinds of
you know
people will trade you
hundreds of dollars worth of items
whatever it may be
for you know ten dollars worth of dope
just because they need it at the time
you know
bucket
and anthony what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life most important lesson
um
i would say i'm going to say that again
every relationship runs its course you
know what i mean
and you create your own
situation
you know
whether
you go to college or don't
or
you know
go to work or whatever it is you do you
know
you're where you are because that's
where you want to be
realistically you know
all right anthony thank you so much for
sharing your story
all right thank you enjoy your ice cream
i'll get you a spoon
you